(audience clapping)
So excited to be here.
Thank you so much for having me.
I'm so excited to talk to you.
I remember,
the first time I met you was because
I went to your show as an audience member.
There's really nothing more exciting
than doing a whole show
and then learning after the fact that
Drew Barrymore was sitting there the whole time.
And then you're like
what?
What just happened?
And then since then
it's just been a blossoming relationship
and I'm grateful to you.
I am too.
And I am glad, cause we are getting to know each other
and I was so excited to learn your design junkie?
Oh, I love it, I love decorating stuff.
I mean, I'm not, like,
I don't really know too much about it, but I love it.
I love looking at interiors.
Like, I love to walk down the street
at night when everybody's lights are on in their home,
and like, I like to look inside their apartments and houses.
(Drew laughs)
(audience chuckling)
It's a healthy stalking of homes.
Yes. Gentle stalking.
I like a gentle stalking.
I feel like I'm a gentle stalker.
Have you used any of your, like, at home time,
like, this past year to spruce things up?
Where are you at in design?
What are you putting around you?
What's your aesthetic and actionability on it all?
Sure, we definitely, we actually bought a house
prior to the pandemic.
And so, we've been kind of putting it together slowly
over time and it's been really fun.
I love my house now so much.
I do enjoy it.
I love a little, I love a little feathered nest
and we built a garden in the backyard.
So, we spent the whole summer eating too many tomatoes.
(audience laughing)
All that stuff, all that good stuff, all that home stuff.
That is, like, the dream.
Did you think when, like, your younger self existed
on the planet that you would ever have, like,
family cozy kitchen and like gorging on tomatoes?
Absolutely not, no,
it just wasn't even, no, it was not something
I ever thought was possible.
So, it's been, I think, really a Godsend during the pandemic
to have a place where we can gather.
And I'm really grateful for that, yeah.
I keep thinking lately that growing up is not overrated,
it's kind of awesome.
Yeah, I feel like I'm kind of at the height
of my powers as a human and I think it only gets better.
I'm kind of looking forward to my eighties.
That's where I'm gonna start wearing a bikini
(audience laughing)
I'm just gonna like hit the Beaches of Ibiza
and do all kinds of stuff I never did.
And do, you have like a beautiful family?
I always admire couples who like work together
and collaborate, that's such a fantasy to me.
You know, for many years you guys worked together.
Oh, there you are.
Yeah, there we are together.
Yeah, I mean, we've worked together since,
so we've been together for about 24 years now.
I can't ever remember how long we've been married
but it's like around 20 years,
That's awful, I'm really bad at dates and stuff.
But, like, around 20 years,
and we have three kids and we've just always collaborated.
The only thing that's changed
about us collaborating is that the scale has changed.
So now people actually watch the collaborations
that we make
(laughing)
as opposed to just us.
And we're all better off for it.
But, how has your power designing together?
Okay, so we were pulling all the threads
of this house together and Jason has,
he likes to think, like, he imagines for himself that
he doesn't have any opinion, and anything is fine with him.
But then, when it comes time
to actually put the thing into the house,
he is extremely opinionated,
like, on the day that it goes in.
So,
(Audience laughs)
we have a set of stairs, they were really slippery.
They were wood stairs.
And I was like, Jason,
I'm going to put carpet on the stairs,
so I don't fall down and, like, break my neck.
And he was like,
"Yeah, whatever, I don't care, I don't even care."
And then the day they brought the carpet to put it in
he was like,
"I don't want, what are we doing carpet for?
I don't need carpet. What do we need carpet for?
We're not gonna fall down the stairs."
I'm like Jason,
"You can't say, when they're installing the carpet,
that you no longer want,
(Drew chuckles)
you have to decide", I'm like,
"you have to talk to me about it in advance,
and then we can decide together"
Now, as the last question, I just wanna ask, like,
if you had, like,
a design aesthetic
or you have a designer or, like, a company
that encompasses you, or multi, like, what would be
a little Samantha Bee home mood board?
Would it be a little of this magazine,
a little of that store, A little of that era?
Yeah, I think it's, like, kind of woodsy.
I think it's, like, a little bit of, maybe,
like, a little bit of bringing nature inside,
but not too much.
Like, I love like a wallpaper that has creatures on it,
or I love, you know, I like lots of, I like wood,
I like wood inside, and a little bit neutral,
you know, remember, like, when ACDC would play all the time,
they'd be like, the guitarist has to go to a white room
and calm down for three hours after every concert he plays.
That's how I feel in my house,
I'm like, yeah I gotta, like,
be in a place where I can just, like,
calm down but also have a couple of cute things to look at.
I did not know that, I'm so caught up
in the detail of this guy had to go sit
in a white room for three hours.
I don't know if that's true,
but that was what I was told when I was, like, growing up
and listening to ACDC, they were like,
"Yeah, Angus has to go to a white cupboard somewhere"
Oh it was Angus, and he
went in this little, like, school boy outfit.
Yeah, he's like take his tie off,
and he just has to sit there and breathe.
And I honestly, that's how I think of my living room.
(chuckling)
It's ridiculous, I don't know why.
I love everything about that answer so much that
I wanna just continue to keep unpacking it
throughout my day and carry it with me.
Samantha Bee
(audience cheering)
Full Frontal airs Wednesdays at 10.30,
9.30 central on TBS in its sixth season.
It's the best show ever.
And you are the best.
(playful upbeat music)